cobra kai has been at the top of
netflix's streaming parts during the
pandemic
omg that is so cool so how cool has it
been
discovering this new audience during
these difficult times
it's been super exciting i think that
was something i was you know i keep
saying like i anticipated it to do
well i didn't think we were gonna do
badly i thought you know netflix would
be a great new home for us
but i didn't expect quite the response
from people being like
yes this is what we wanted i was like oh
cool like this is what i wanted to give
you i just didn't know you wanted it
it's really exciting to get to see how
much people have really taken
taken to heart the karate kid the cobra
kai all of it
i thought we were the good guys
we try to be there's one thing i do know
for sure
you can't run away from your problems
i am really grateful i'm so this whole
karate kid
fandom and everything else has been
they're so embracing and
so cool and i've it's been great to be a
part of i mean it's really shocking i
think i remember driving in the car
and i think it was my parents calling me
and being like did you know that cobra
kai is trending right now
on netflix and it has been and even
everyone telling us and i remember just
sitting in my car
and you know we're isolated right now
and we're alone at home but also it
feels like we have this
huge support and it's really given me a
lot to look forward to
and something to be proud of throughout
this time and i'm really grateful for it
that is awesome and something else to
look forward to you guys have already
been locked down for season four
and season three hasn't even come out
yet that is awesome
how does it feel for you guys what was
your reaction when you heard you guys
are going for season four
i bawled my eyes out i was so happy i
remember
they wanted to zoom us like all the
writers got everyone together all the
actors and everyone together to zoom
and i remember just trying not i don't
know why i didn't want to show everyone
that i was just like
sitting there and then afterwards i
think i just sometimes i just sit in my
kitchen and i scream
because i'm so excited i'm so excited
you know to get to to see my castmates
to see my cobra kai family it's been
a long minute so i'll be really excited
to get to get back in there with
everybody i'm so excited to get back to
kicking and punching things because
that's like the most fun it's all the
aggressors yeah exactly
all that anger i got for 2020 is getting
delivered whoever is receiving these
punches better be ready
i know that i am in a very lucky
position right now that a lot of people
are not in to have a little bit of job
certainty
and of course everything can change in a
heartbeat because that's the way the
world works we all learn that this year
but i'm really grateful that uh that
we've got this next season i'm really
excited and you guys are going to be
getting back to some intense
physicalities on that set
we're mentioning mary you can take out
that aggression on 2020 yeah
and this season was raiden supreme on
that front so
break it down for us what kind of
training were you going through
for some of these scenes i mean we had
all the stunt doubles all the stuff
coordinators all the actors together
it was a huge rehearsal i mean just in
terms of the amount of people
we get hours to train and everything
else i never feel fully ready until i'm
there in the moment i'm like all right
you got to go for it and just commit
i love our training process you know as
much time as we can get but a lot of
time
being that we you know we filmed this
show on a pretty quick turnaround so we
don't always get a ton of time to
do our rehearsals so especially for our
episode 10 fight last couple seasons
it's kind of like
everything kind of runs up to that point
that by the time you get to episode 10
it's like oh crap we're episode 10
like everybody be better be ready so
like all season you're like yeah yeah
we're gonna start rehearsing episode
yeah yeah i read that script it looks
really good i'm excited to see that come
to life
and then you get your uh your rehearsals
for the first time and you're like oh
crap i've got like two days
to be able to pull this off cool cool
great speaking of episode 10
it gets intense y'all real quick and
so that being said i mean we have a huge
cliffhanger again for season three
are you seeing scripts all ready for
season four what can we expect what are
they cooking up
i wish they're smart enough to keep all
that under wraps until we're already
locked down in atlanta
we're already like chained to the table
and they're like all right now we'll
tell you
like everything is even more buttoned up
than ever i was asking for the trailer
like the day before it came out
and they said no you get it in the
morning when it comes out so i feel like
i'm hearing about everything
when everyone else is well y'all clue me
in whenever you get you know when you're
looked into what's going on for season
four i'd love to get some dates you know
maybe by the time we're filming episode
10 we'll have some info yeah
exactly right i love it i'd love to see
will smith in there as well
since he is he's so fun has he ever come
to set
no but we have had kayla pinkett has
been was around for especially during
season one i know he's got a lot of
other projects now that he's gotta kind
of split up his time on but he hung out
around a lot during season one that was
really cool
i mean we need to get will back into the
set we need the fresh prince coming over
to yeah yeah
why you know what i'm saying watch fresh
prince in my trailer every day on cobra
kai and i didn't even put it together
that was i don't know so i love it
it's more of a like a good cop bad cop
situation actually it's
more of a no cop situation you do
realize neither one of you are cops
right
yeah but we got the information we
needed the guy coughed it up like a
chicken bone
he cried we see johnny and daniel's
relationship look they have been on
separate pages for 35 years now and
maybe or maybe not
they might be coming to some sort of a
truce maybe what would it take
to end this rivalry once and for all i'm
just thinking of
the time they went on the double date
sort of thing at the mexican restaurant
yeah oh my god i love that moment
like some more drinks and double dates
and uh talking about
everything and just i don't know being
happy and also just wanting peace
between the kids i think might end up
bringing them together it's like we
gotta stop this and we gotta be adults
and be bigger than that
so maybe that's the conversation i'll
have say i think it's gonna be alcohol
and dude stuff that would kind of be the
thing like you know what i mean like the
like the speed wagon thing like it's
gotta be like dude stuff that like
brings them together
[Music]